I think the WSL is creating so much
revenue at the minute and even women's
football in America is you know really
equal to the men's game as well I think
it's not equal at all if you look at
profits it's not even close it's not
equal but in terms of the people that
are watching the game and spending money
on the game you know it's making so much
money to what it was you know even five
years ago and I don't see there's any
issue compared to yeah if it's
unprofitable and that's again which goes
back to the problem women's sports don't
tend to make money they do tend to make
money it tends to be their monetizing
sexuality in some way really by and
large women's sports do not make money